سنخرج دائمًا على رأس الشر ،
هذه الأكاذيب في صميم تقاليدنا ولكن
أيضًا تقاليدك ،
لكن الأفق لا يظل واضحًا
لفترة من الوقت بمجرد هزيمة الشر القديم ،
يحاول الشخص الجديد رفع رأسه ،
هل لديك شعور  أن الشر سوف
ينهار مرة أخرى
أستطيع أن أراه
في عينيك الآن نحن نفكر بنفس الطريقة
التي نعلم أن الحرية ستفوز بها ، نعلم أننا نعلم أن
روسيا ستخسر
ونحن نعلم حقًا أن
النصر سيغير العالم وهذا
سوف  يكون التغيير الذي طالما احتاجه العالم ،
المملكة المتحدة
تسير معنا نحو أكثر ما
أعتقد أنه أهم انتصار في
حياتنا سيكون انتصارًا على
فكرة العالم
بعد أن ذهبنا معًا أي معتد
لا  مهما كان كبيرا أو صغيرا سيعرف
ما الذي ينتظره إذا هاجم
النظام الدولي أي
معتد أي
معتد سيحاول دفع
العصابات بالقوة من شأنه إلحاق
الدمار والموت بالشعوب الأخرى
التي ستحاول تحمل ديكتاتوريته
على حساب السابق.
دماء الآخرين في
الحروب الإجرامية وغير المبررة كما يفعل الكرملين ، أي
معتد سيخسر